All right, this is this is fun and scary at
the same time, I love a good conspiracy theory.
Many of you know, I've been fascinated by
scams and conspiracies since I was a kid.
And I love seeing how do people get convinced
of such such wacky things that none of us
should be believing in and that lems and essential
oils and all, you know, all these different
scam products and all this different stuff.
OK, if you want to read a book, by the way,
about large scale scams and and cults and
a lot of a lot of scams are also cultish,
like with memes, that's often the case.
Check out the book, The Road to Jonestown
about Jim Jones and the People's Temple.
And this is the origin of the term to drink
the Kool-Aid.
It came tragically from from the People's
Temple and Jim Jones.
OK, here is a conspiracy that comes to us
from Newsmax, which is one of the two networks
that Donald Trump has been recommending as
a truly right wing alternative to Fox News.
Remember, Trump and some of his most ardent
suck up followers have been attacking Fox
News lately as being liberal now because they
acknowledge that Joe Biden won the election,
that makes them liberal now.
And the theory put forward by Newsmax, and
I'm using the word theory in the colloquial
sense, not the scientific sense theory, very
loose colloquial usage.
We're going to look at some clips in a moment.
The theory is as follows.
Kamala Harris, senator from California, has
not yet resigned her Senate seat, even though
Kamala Harris is the vice president elect
and will be sworn in on January 20th.
She is still a senator.
She's not resigned and she can vote in the
Senate.
And her Senate term actually goes until 2023.
If she were not to resign because she's going
to be VP at some point between now and January
20th, Kamala Harris will resign.
And that will clear the seat for California
Governor Gavin Newsom to select a replacement.
The theory goes on Newsmax that the reason
Kamala Harris hasn't resigned is because it's
an insurance policy, because deep down, Kamala
knows she suspects.
Maybe she knows that it's actually not going
to be.
Joe Biden sworn in on January 20th.
Deep down, this is this is not my view.
Right?
I'm telling you the theory.
Deep down, Comilla suspects Trump will be
getting a second term, not Biden.
So she's staying in the Senate so that when
she doesn't become vice president on January
20th, she can stay in the Senate until January
of twenty twenty three.
That's the theory.
Let's check out some clips.
This first one is a Newsmax host.
I don't know if it's pronounced grant stink
field or stench field.
These are names we may have to become familiar
with as media critics for the next couple
of years.
Here is Grant Stink Field explaining what's
going on with Kamala.
Here's the reason they want Senator Kamala
Harris to be promptly inserted as president.
And may I remind you, Hereth is a woman who
has yet to resign from the United States Senate
in preparation of becoming the next vice president
and ultimately president.
If the media gets their way, why hasn't she
resigned yet?
Because maybe, like all of us, she still thinks
President Trump has a shot at victory if only
all the evidence of fraud can be proven and
exposed.
So that's the idea.
Comilla suspects she may not really end up
being the vice president.
So she's holding on to that Senate seat.
Here's another Newsmax host.
This is Greg Kelly, who suggested the exact
same thing just a few days prior to Grant
Stringfield mentioning it.
Take a listen.
By the way, I think the Biden people aren't
as confident as they are trying to convey.
You know, Kamala Harris has not resigned her
seat, I'm told yet.
And the United States Senate, Barack Obama,
when he won back in 2008, he resigned before
Thanksgiving.
I think they're just keeping their options
open depending on what happens.
So there's the same idea from another Newsmax
host, Greg Kelly.
Now, this this maybe could actually be instructive.
Any time you're presented with a conspiracy
theory, you should know the process to go
through to evaluate it.
And before you even start evaluating the conclusions
of the theory, you have to start with fact
checking the premises.
The first question would be, is it true that
Kamala Harris has not resigned from the Senate
yet?
That is true.
OK, that's step one.
Number two, is it unusual that she hasn't
resigned yet halfway through December before
a January swearing in?
Well, it is true that Barack Obama did resign
his seat in mid-November, in 2008 when he.
Won the presidential election.
That part is true, but what's unusual is how
early Barack Obama did it.
It's very unusual.
If you just go back to 2008, then Senator
Joe Biden didn't resign from the Senate until
five days before he was inaugurated as VP
in 2009.
George W. Bush didn't resign as Texas governor
until late December.
In the year 2000, Bill Clinton didn't resign
as governor of Arkansas in 1992 until very
late December.
Al Gore didn't resign as senator until January
of 1993, even later than Bill Clinton, when
Al Gore was set to become the vice president.
George H.W. Bush's vice president, Dan Quayle
didn't resign from the Senate until January
of the inauguration.
So there is nothing unusual going on here.
And that's where the conspiracy theory falls
apart.
It's predicated on everybody else has resigned
so early.
No, no, no, no, no.
The truth is almost nobody has already resigned
in mid-December when they are set to be inaugurated
as president or VP in late January of the
following year.
So the most likely reason why Kamala Harris
is not yet resigning is that no one, typically,
that's how it works.
So she's doing what most other people do.
And number two, she wants to be able to vote
in the Senate because it's not clear how quickly
California Governor Gavin Newsom will be ready
to replace her.
And you don't want to have an empty seat in
the Senate when Democrats want to have as
many votes as possible, including possibly
on very important things like a second coronavirus
stimulus package.
So this is another very silly conspiracy theory,
and we are likely to hear many more of them
on Newsmax.
And I know and and I'm sure on Fox News as
well over the next two to four years.
And in fact, I want to go next to talk about
Fox News briefly.
So
as I've told you before,